Okay,
should be live here.
I'm starting to try to get back to work
properly here.
I got some good sleep.
Went for a little run this morning.
Doing a little bit more lifting.
Trying to get my mind back in the right
state. Um,
I think the key thing at the moment is
that there is there's quite a bit a lot
of leftover stuff from 40 and it really
just needs to be fully fully finished
before I can do
um stuff on Puffer 5,
I think. So, I got a couple client
projects
that
we're not really behind on because they
were both delayed, but um like they were
on their end also delayed, but now we're
circling back to finish those. Uh one of
those I can actually do on stream
because it's open source.
Couple larger client things as well I
have to check in on. Um, we have several
environment PRs from contributors that
need to be merged. Be doing those on
stream.
The Inferno environment, of course, I'd
like to get a reasonable model uh that
can do the whole thing. We've got
selfplay integration. We've got lots and
lots of things. Uh, and we have a few
side projects as well. Hi, Robin.
So, uh, what I want to do today,
unless Robin is here with, uh, an NPR to
look at first,
um, I have a little bit of work on the
open source environment for one of the
clients, and I think I can probably just
finish the full thing today. Frankly, I
don't think it should be that that
difficult. Project is almost done, and
there were just some tests and things to
be added.
Let's see if we have a um I bet you we
have an NPR from Robin here though,
right?
Let me just Let's take a quick look at
this.
Um yeah, that end should definitely just
work out of the box.
Somebody add Flappy Puff.
Funny.
Wait. Huh?
I'm confused because this got merged.
So, how is this plus 879?
I thought I merged an early version,
didn't I?
But wait, why is this now showing as an
all new um why is this showing as
completely new?
Take a look at that and figure out
what's something's weird there.
constellation include all ocean ends. Uh
all the stable ones minus I think there
are a couple small ones we didn't sweep
crit that uh we'd still want sweeps for,
but pretty much all of them.
Like it'll work for anything of course.
You just need to sweep it. like
obviously um have it be was it sweep and
be like puffer four compatible
Yeah, there's no way we need this many
[ __ ] rewards for this.
No way.
It's much cleaner. This is going to take
me some time to go through though to try
to figure out why it's not training for
you.
I will do a second pass review on this,
but I want to do um I want to finish
this client project while I'm fresh.
I've got pretty limited energy left in
me still.
I'm still ramping back up after the uh
and the 40 release just totally wiped
me.
That was a lot of work.
I'll merge it for now, though.
I'm probably just going to have to go
through and run some stuff.
No, we're not [ __ ] asking Claude or
Codeex. Get that. Get those worms out of
your brain.
Okay, this is not too too much code.
This is fine.
Can work with this
Start training.
Uh, Anish, I'm going to go through it
and I'm going to actually see if I can
help you get it working, but not right
now. Like, I have two different clients
that have stuff that they need done.
This one is actually just so happens to
be open source, so I'm streaming some
stuff on it, but uh, this needs to be
done and I've only got so much energy in
me at the moment. Like,
I don't know. It's been a few weeks, but
I still just feel totally wiped from 40.
life.
There definitely is not social stuff
going like I'm in the middle of nowhere
here, man.
this is the annoying thing about having
these projects drag across like this. I
really need to be able to do projects in
one take or I just lose context for what
the hell I've done.
Yeah, four is a lot.
It's been like 3 weeks at least, but I'm
just like
I'm sort of starting to remember a
little bit what I was doing here.
uh this specific one I am man
this specific one is open source so yes
if the end isn't Open source. Obviously
not.
Of course, you're not going to see very
much interesting until I remember what
the heck I was doing. I haven't touched
this in a couple months.
I don't think I would have left it with
the test failing either.
So something's off my mind. Something is
off here.
I'm reveal more things. Been building
buffer for lawyers. still kind of gluing
though. Offer for lawyers that probably
makes sense that you're gluing some
[ __ ] It depends what you want to do,
man.
I can only speak to the type of stuff I
can do. I'm not really looking for like,
oh, gaps where I can like do something
that fills a need or whatever. I'm
looking for how I do fundamentally new
stuff, right?
and being able to see things from the
lens of Perf, from the lens of what is
physically possible rather from from the
lens of like what I can cobble together.
Yeah. Okay. I think I just screwed up
the test at some point then.
I don't know what like this doesn't make
sense to me that this would have been um
like this.
Somehow the config just got screwed up.
Okay.
Congrats. I mean, look, if you're
looking to if you're looking to build a
company and like that's very different
from looking at software as a craft and
looking at like what are the things that
you can fundamentally create that are
new. It's they're just very different
objectives
and
I mean, to give you an idea like
the amount of work that O took
like I basically completely burnt out
the part of my brain that has all of the
drive in order to do things.
Uh and it's been 3 weeks and I'm still
exhausted. Like it's going to probably
be another few weeks more before that
comes back. Um and that includes like
basic drive to like you know pick stuff
up and like you know do whatever very
very few chores I even have to do and
like go outside in a walk or like do any
sort of exercise which I normally have a
ton of motivation to do. though.
But I mean, genuinely, that's what it
took to get that release done.
Just a very, very complicated thing.
Just need a Runescape break, bro. All
right. This is the leagues account. The
leagues has been out for like two weeks
and uh almost at the same total level as
my main. Go on leagues obviously.
And we're AFKing Serrainus because the
build is so broken that I can just not
click it.
Just kill Serrainus.
Oh, we also have the other side monitor
with 111k stardust from the last couple
weeks.
I remember the first week after the
release,
I was too tired to even relax properly.
Like I think I spent a full day one
ticking Kuram once
because that just seemed like that was
just the mood.
Okay, I think I remember enough of what
this is. Let me go through the stuff
that I need to do for today on
right, we can do this.
Diet and sleep. Diet's good.
Sleep has been like okay. Could be
better. Um, I'm definitely doing better
on that now.
I don't know. It's just I usually have
quite a quite good levels of motivation
for stuff and
let's get burnt.
So, I'm kind of just like chilling and
doing what I can. I'm going to like
clean up. The goal is this week to do as
much as I can without like really trying
to push it too much to um clean up stuff
for clients from like 340 stuff um to
integrate some environments.
Mostly what I'm doing sort of ramping
that stuff back up.
You need this here.
You don't. Why have I been doing that?
Is it because of this? I think you need
to cast here, right?
No, you don't.
Is that a C++?
We should probably spend some time
cleaning up these tests before we add
more.
I guess I can just do allocate and free,
right?
this is still flexible. This is
automating the one portion where it's
like definitely always going to be the
same.
Have you seen puffer drive?
We developed this with um with NYU.
Currently, training is up to 300,000
steps per second on one GPU.
Getting some very nice behaviors. This
includes the Carla maps as well. And uh
there's some major speed ups in
development as well on this to be able
to get it to a few million steps per
second.
No hierarchy was required for this. Just
straight
Great high throughput RL
track and collision data
web data. Uh I think we just use the
points here. We have road points. We
have uh points for other cars. I think
it's just a bunch of different point uh
a different bunch of different point
encodings.
All open source. You can check on them.
They have some publications as well.
I've seen some of the original Carla
stuff. Um, a lot of the early like sim
bindings with that are just so unusably
slow. So, you think you need very fancy
complicated approaches, but you really
don't. You just need fast engineering.
You can just download this and run this
locally. It's also these I mean these
are agents in your browser like the
neural net is just running in your
browser here.
Uh if you're doing research about the
hierarchical approach, then I wouldn't
use driving as a problem. It's a very
messy problem uh with very slow sims.
Like it's you pick one, right? If you
want to study the approach, you pick a a
very clean like high throughput problem.
And if you want to like fix a specific
problem, right? Then you use a more
standard approach. You don't just have
everything be uncontrolled at the same
time. I wouldn't be able to get
something to work in that setting. And
I've been doing this for over a decade.
That's why I activate
When I activate Sim, Carlo starts to go
slow.
If you have a language model in the
loop. Yeah. Like the sim is slow, the
model is slow, every part of that is
slow.
I mean, even like at the moment, drive
is one of the slowest ends we have. Um,
and it's still 300,000 steps per second.
It's still like 10,000 times faster than
a lot of what's out there.
And no worries. I hope that's not
discouraging. Like
I know there are a lot of people trying
to do research um on these really slow
Sims. It's just not a fun place to be.
Why is YouTube capping quality at 480p?
My stream sure as hell is not at 480p.
You think realistically
it's very tough in RL. like
there's just a lot of really screwy
research in RL
where it's like I don't even have to
read the contents because I can just
tell you based on the approach that
stuff is doomed.
It's like your sim is slow. Your methods
don't work when stuff is slow.
Therefore, nothing else matters. Your
thing will not work.
test here is too long
like this.
Oh, because it's the same first step.
No, it's not. Okay. So, this is the new
number
Okay. So, we want to do testing
negotiations.
I I can actually just do this in the
other test, can't I?
I just got to test the timeout stuff.
This is fine.
bilateral two agents working at the same
time. Um can be yeah
These are like some specific tests that
the uh the client wanted to have.
special I need to do to debug it with
all the new C stuff.
Um
did you update like does it have the
numbum agents field?
It needs to have the numbum agents
field. It needs to have the
like float
uh ops and stuff
I need to do to debug it with all the
new
I think you can just run GDB on it can't
you
like
it still gets compiled with um the end
code still gets compiled as C it's
statically linked you should just be
able to run it through GDB Okay.
Does anybody see anything wrong with
this? Like
You define like the OB spaces and stuff
with the binding, right? Captain
D type all that
shouldn't be too many things to
All right, I'll be right back
the restroom real quick. Do a couple
things
and then I will see if we can figure
this out.
I'm doing a little bit of client work on
um one of the MS that happens to be open
source.
Yeah, compute marketplace
just like a bunch of tests and like
loading in some data, training some
models. Um trying to finish up this
milestone of the uh the project.
We're quite delayed.
I have absolutely no idea what's wrong.
It just looks like it's straight
skipping an LF.
It's like just straight skipping the
check cuz I'm out.
I don't see any like weird syntax that
would cause this.
This can't be it. If I'm this dumb then
like no way.
All right.
I don't feel dumb about that. I don't
know why GDB does that. Why the [ __ ] it
even gets to this
That's a problem.
Is that a problem?
Not much. I'm um
I am currently just finishing. This is a
client end that happens to be open
source
and I am cleaning it up.
Getting ready to
have this thing done.
No storage.
Okay. Give it some storage.
Um,
off by one.
Yeah, we're just off by one. Hang on.
Okay, now we're just at 100.
So presumably
Okay.
Um,
- 11, right?
- 9.
some of the requests I'm getting here
are just like
I have to read them 10 times to sort of
figure out what they mean.
Okay. So, they want a storage test, I
guess.
Okay. I think I can do this.
Kind of wonky, but I can do this. Let me
get um
me get a quick set in
PB price will be
on.
It does change the order. things,
doesn't it?
So, I think that this has to go here.
Yeah, this has to go here because
otherwise every single time I change
anything like just adding logic before
Let me just pick one of these specs to
use.
That'll be per node.
Oh, wait. That can't be per How's that
per node?
Oh, I see. I priced those per. That's
fine.
Uh, it doesn't give us.
Let's see if I can get this just off
Google.
I guess I guess
or wait. Compute only.
Okay. So, we'll just do like this.
No, nothing here.
Hey man, I am
currently
working on a compute marketplace sim for
a client that happens to be open source.
I figured I'd stream it today and then
either later today or probably tomorrow
at this point I'm going to have to do uh
there's some closed source client work
and then I'll be back to reviewing NPRs.
And we'll be back to um messing with the
Runescape Simulator environment soon.
I have to get some client stuff done.
I'm trying to figure out how I want to
model this thing. I guess it's just
going to be like small mismatch jobs.
It should be very very easy though, like
to get the best
outcome on I would think.
Guess it's a sanity test of some. It's
sort of a sanity test, right?
multi-objective battery usage
GPO.
Why on earth do you need GRPO for a
battery usage environment? Like that's a
language model algorithm. That's an
absolutely awful algorithm for general
RL. I mean, that's the algorithm you use
when you just cannot learn a value
function. And RL doesn't work without a
value function, which is why these labs
are spending so much bloody money um
trying to do RL because like they don't
have value functions.
like there's no world in which you'd
want to replace
um PO with GRPO if you can do PO
learning the policy directly. But that
you do that in lang like the people that
do language modeling RL do that because
they can't learn a value function
because they're like they're treating
each token as an action which makes it
completely unreasonable to learn a value
function. Like it's basically trying to
learn a value function if your action
space is multi-discretet of a thousand
and like 10,000.
like you you're basically doing fancy
reinforce at that point.
this term fancy reinforce. So like
capital reinforce the algorithm. It's
like the most basic on policy RL
algorithm and it sucks. It's an awful
algorithm. Um
like if you look at what GRPO does, it
is that plus the group regularization
group regularized policy optimization.
It's basically group regularized
reinforce.
Like we already have something similar
to that group rag term, but not over
tons of completions of the same thing.
I always found it weird that people call
that Monte Carlo policy gradient like
in courses. Yeah, courses are really
old. And
look, if you look at a lot of the
classic R outlet, it just straight does
not work, right?
Like basically everything in off policy
is a joke. Doesn't work. Uh a lot of the
modelbased lit is just blatantly false,
borderline scientific fraud. Um a lot of
the fancy algorithms even in on policy
lit are bad and overstated. The thing
that does work is PO and PO derivatives
done at uh the scale of like at large
scale data. So if you just have a high
environment throughput and you can push
a bunch of data through those that
works.
That is what I have seen.
EPO is actor critic. See, like they just
introduce all these stupid [ __ ]
words, right? Like the actor critic
thing just means you have a policy and
you have a value function. PO has a
policy and it has a value function. You
can either share the representation for
those or they can be independent.
Usually you share them.
But like calling it a whole another
class of methods, it's just like
there's just so much like they spend 90%
of the time introducing [ __ ] that
doesn't matter
and then they just like face plant on
the engineering and all their stuff is
so slow that none of it works. Anyways,
if you just read some of the articles
I've published, you'll see some of like
the like the really effective
breakthroughs that have actually made a
big difference.
across a ton of different environments,
very stable, very robust, and it's just
not stuff like that. I mean, we've had a
couple tweaks to PO, but they're not
sexy tweaks, right? They're like pretty
down to earth, reasonable changes. And
we have a new architecture that is like
mostly just hardware aligned, say, hey,
these models we were using don't scale
super well down to smaller sizes, and
they're hard to optimize for the
hardware.
Um, that made a big difference. And then
like some hyperparameter tuning stuff.
Field to write a thesis in. Yeah, I
don't blame you. Of course, it's
confusing. The field's a mess.
I've spent the last few years trying to
make it simpler.
Done a decent job of it. I would say
a heck of a lot simpler than it used to
be at the very least.
I not a single part of that statement
makes any damn sense. Starship, I got no
idea what you're on.
you have like a bunch of fragments of
ideas that make sense, but like
I don't see any reasonable way to stitch
them together, and I can't tell if you
do either.
It's like you're saying a bunch of true
things, but like the puzzle pieces don't
fit together in the way that you think
that they do.
The profit looks really high to me.
Wait, so the profit should be
Oh, no. Actually, that's about the
regime of it.
Um, so it's sort of yes, but
it's not as hardware specific as
something like a modern attention kernel
would be. It should just generally be
faster on everything. Now, uh it is
built for Nvidia hardware, so
like you need CUDA. Um but it's mostly
just like eliminating a bunch of the CPU
overhead.
The target hardware that we use for our
own experiments is kind of just the most
reasonably accessible thing. Um, it's
not like complete crap hardware, but
it's the most reasonably accessible
thing for sort of academic scale stuff,
which is just like um 4090 nodes with
decent CPUs on them. 4090 or 5090 nodes.
You can rent those on vast for 20 to 40
cents an hour. They're super cheap. And
uh then locally for dev, we'll use lower
grade stuff sometimes, you know, like
4070 or whatever. It's like a mid mid a
midspec desktop typically is what you
want to have at the very least. High-end
spec desktop does make things nice and
faster, but if you just have like
honestly if you have anything locally
that you can at least run CUDA on,
you're probably fine. And then you just
run the actual experiments on cheap
rented hardware.
Literally costs less than a cup of
coffee a day to rent. So very
accessible.
Yeah, I I don't like no hallucinations
are not like that's not something that
you can just say ah yes it's attributed
to I can value stretch in Qkv no way I
don't buy that
rundev locally. Yeah. So, I mean that
you can do that. Uh, wait. M370. What is
an M37? That is an Nvidia chip, right?
Oh, it's the laptop one. Yeah, you're
good. You can run uh you can run Puffer
on that
as long as you have an Nvidia chip.
Like, there is a CPU mode, but it's
really not fun. Yeah, 3070 laptop will
that'll be fine. Not going to be as fast
as a 4090 or 5090 obviously, but you
know, for testing stuff that's fine. And
then just I honestly think that the best
workflow is to just have SSH into um
just like a single node that has
reasonable PF um and like simple SSH
access
was my suggestion.
times nodes.
Uh,
I don't like um these stupid
Python DSLs for CUDA. That's right. CUDA
Yeah. On our hardware though for our
test ends we can get 10 to 20 million.
Setting something up on my side on the
side There.
I think we can probably just like train
this and this.
Oops.
Power budgets.
Okay, I still have to add that in, but
we'll do this for now.
seller sideed
buyer
uh what did we say 10?
I didn't say right
Yeah. I mean, there's really no room for
sophistication at all here.
dict doesn't get dynamically. Ah,
yeah. I really need to have a warning or
something on that.
Yeah, you can't you can't PR doubling it
to 64. You double the memory on all the
freaking logs.
You also really should not have that
many logs. We had one other dude do that
as well. Um, I will fix that so that the
so that it actually properly either
expands or warns you, but we really
don't need people having a bajillion log
items
way.
Um,
I just had this AFKing
and uh
234 for a vis.
Okay,
that's [ __ ] awesome.
I was about to leave like, "All right,
this isn't worth it." I literally was
about to click over to go leave and then
it's like, "Oh,
okay.
That's pretty cool."
This was like uh Yeah, this one doesn't
have a render.
How does that even happen? Probably
horribly scaled data.
I would imagine OB's data being scaled
badly.
So, all I have to do is add the energy
thing to this and then uh and then we
should be able to outperform it.
Old obs on the default neural net. If
it's on the default, it should be fine
then.
How's leagues going?
Man, I just got like a 200k vis just
afking um
Brutal Blues and Corand,
so I can't complain.
The update on that is 36k
points.
Uh
50 mil rune crafting, mining,
uh fire making, wood cutting.
Things are aggressive, right? Yeah. We
just sit here
like sit here.
I mean, I needed sort I sort of needed a
break after four,
you know.
Yeah, I'm also I'm doing it on my um I'm
doing it on my pure. I'm not even doing
it on my main because my main is here
collecting 113k stardust.
running at 99 mining.
I took all three raid regions, which
in retrospect,
I could have just ditched I could have
ditched the desert
um and taken Canderin for way better
mage gear
and
That might have been better. I wanted to
have all three raid regions though.
Oh, see you. See you around.
Well, yeah, that crossbow is pretty
good, isn't it?
I think
that one only really gives you
That's like blind bag region, isn't it?
But not even really if you want a bunch
of god swords.
But then the people that are really
doing that are just camping top until
they get three sides.
Next. Yeah.
I don't know. I have like 900 next Casey
on main game. I'm good with that boss.
Go check the spec that I was modeling on
this
We kind of need it to be able to buy
energy, don't it?
Yeah,
I think that's the issue is we need the
um agent needs to just be able to buy
buy the energy.
The frack is 0.0. Well, that's awful.
Don't have that.
I don't know how you get zero clip rack.
That's like an invalid config.
It really shouldn't nan out. Like, it
shouldn't instantly nan out. I guess if
you set like gigantic learning rate or
something, you could, but we've had
stuff be pretty stable lately.
defaults are used including the default
model size then it should be fine.
I don't know could be partially ported
config like some of the parameter names
and stuff changed.
I have to look at it. I'm finishing this
at the moment. got kind of limited
energy
until uh fully back from uh
the 40 madness.
All right, let's see how this is
computed.
depends on your skill set.
We've had people contribute to the core
infrastructure for 40. You know, some
good systems. Research side stuff is
definitely possible as well if you know
that side. It's just that the end stuff
tends to be the most accessible piece of
it.
Definitely possible to become competent
in research.
Spencer's done it in the last year or
so.
Does take some effort.
that's one of the things like right now
Spencer and Jess are working on that.
But I mean it can also be like an
example of core research stuff would be
the things that I did in the puffer 3
algorithm as well as the architecture
with mining, right? It's not just like,
oh, go implement this, right? That's not
how research works.
It's like, go figure out with very high
certainty like that. Go find a thing
that's better than this with very high
certainty, run comprehensive
experiments, and then replace it stably.
Like, you can see why that's pretty
tough to do,
It works
now.
Problem is there's not that much
expense.
I need to do something for a test that I
can like
Okay, cool. Now there should actually be
some room for optimization.
I have no idea what that I don't know
what the point of that is actually.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
We should be able to learn this better,
I would think.
Yeah, I can do that, Captain. Let me
finish this.
I just want to finish this thing up.
Yeah, Eastern at the moment, but I will
be going to California soon.
Sweep work or nah. Um, it doesn't look
like it. Let me see.
It's kind of the same best as very early
in the sweep.
0.95.
I guess we can go look. I think
something's wrong though, Vault, because
what the bug that we had, right? It was
able to do the full inferno in only a
few minutes when um Zuck starts in
enrage phase starts at 240
with healers and Jad.
So, the most mechanically difficult part
of the fight.
It's fine.
Somehow it's dying in the middle of
that. I, you know, the fact that it
keeps taking random zuck hits.
I'm almost suspicious of like something
being off in that fight because it's
just been so difficult to not get it to
just take random zuck hits. and
pretty much everything else like that it
learns almost instantly and perfectly.
But I looked at the obs and they looked
reasonable. So unless like the safe the
safe indicator is getting computed wrong
or something.
Also, I got like a 230 KC vis on leagues
AFKing this on the the other monitor.
There.
Yeah, I something just seems wrong to me
with it.
Well, there's this awesome thing that's
out for another month and a half called
leagues.
I got to say, if you look at some of the
retention numbers on this game, it's
pretty insane. like pick any random game
on Steam and it'll be like 50% completed
the tutorial and then it's like 10%
completed the first level within the
first 10 minutes of the game and it's
just kind of ridiculous.
And with this one it's like I think it's
six or 7% of the people who got 2k
points uh got like the freaking dragon
cup.
So
that's kind of insane to me.
People really like this game.
It's funny that like the league's
progression rate would probably still be
considered slow by any other game
standards.
If you go play WoW, like literally
within a few days, you're max level as a
new brand new player not knowing the
game at all.
And then you just get like timegated,
literal time gated gear progression.
It's like weekly [ __ ]
Then you have this which is like
unapologetic 500 hour midame grind.
Screw you.
I think that's kind of only the
streamers
that do like infinite numbers of uh
hardcore accounts.
I think most people just have a main and
then they maybe have like um PvP alt or
an iron or whatever, but like that's
kind of it.
Like I just have um I have my main and I
have a 50 attack pure
Yeah. I don't I don't know how many
people play dead man. It's a Is it a lot
that one takes way more time investment?
I think
like leagues you can kind of just do on
your schedule if you want. And yeah,
it's fun to do the week one rush and
stuff, right? It's fun. Like it was
super fun having I had Infinity before
almost anybody else had it. It was
pretty fun running around with that. Um
but like you can kind of just play the
game however.
But with Dead Man it's like oh you
started two days late. Good luck.
A lot more chill.
I think if nonpkers like it, then they
just like it because they're swapping
gold.
The problem is like
the skill floor in this game for PvP is
so ludicrously high.
I didn't think dead man really didn't
seem worth it to me. Unless it's like,
yeah, I'm just going to go do this for
the week,
whatever. All right.
The league's rewards being worth
basically nothing is kind of [ __ ]
I think it's probably just it's way too
easy to get the rewards or something.
They're just too many of them in the
game.
It's kind of sad to have like have that
be worth basically nothing.
I'm not going to complain about all the
ornament kits that they had though
cuz uh ornament kits know your death
fee.
Right. So, what I was going to do to
figure this out is
Yeah. So, this somehow is just not
getting reward for this.
Unless it's really small.
Oh, okay. Well, there's your c there's
your problem.
Um, I'm not really going to start that
vault until I have everything else under
control for the time being. We got to do
some business side stuff. We got to
merge a bunch of ends. We got to run
some experiments. But it's it's based on
go explore
the idea.
very roughly.
No. Um um people have not really been
working on it. It's just like vault.
It's it's a type of it's a technique
where it's essentially impossible.
It's a technique that addresses a
problem that's not addressed in any way
by current algorithms. And it's
virtually impossible to address it any
other way.
I'd be very surprised if this doesn't if
it does not work. It's going to
obviously be difficult and it's going to
take a lot of venge and experimentation,
but
it should work.
It's meant to address the exact issue
that we have with the inferno with the
curriculum, which is like you have to do
the entire thing to get back to the
point that you failed.
It's not just sparsity. It's a very
specific type of thing.
Okay. Rewards just aren't wired up
correctly, I'd assume.
Another explanation.
Use the restroom real quick. Get another
set in or two and then um we will fix
this. Hopefully this is not too tough
and we will continue. The optimization
is working correctly. It's just the
reward deaths are wrong. I'm sure of it.
historical weights,
no speed from single agent to this.
Okay, that's awesome.
Um, you want to look at that in a bit,
Spencer? I want to finish this current
client shenanigans.
I'm finishing um archive stuff.
It's open source, so I'm streaming it.
Um
and then I got the other one tomorrow,
but I think just we can do we can go
over some stuff tonight for this.
after cleaning it up. I'm It's going to
be a few hours for me.
Maybe not a few hours. Maybe like two,
hour and a half, two hoursish, I think.
I don't know. It's hard to tell.
I've got um there's a couple last bugs
to fix and then I think we're good. We
will see.
Can you look on stream? I want to watch.
Uh, sure.
I do want to finish this thing first.
I don't know. It could just be that I
could finish this up and we're good. If
you point me to the branch, DM me the
branch or put the branch in the dev chat
or whatever.
I think it still is LAR, man.
like
you're doing it because the AI is so
[ __ ]
but like the solution is not to wrangle
your entire codebase to be worse in
order to support like garbage code being
written by garbage devs, in this case by
the stupid LLMs. The solution is to just
not be [ __ ] stupid.
It's tough in the case of a port of
something so big though, right? Like
presumably we could cut the codebase
size down a ton and also speed it up a
I don't know. I'm way happier when I'm
working with code bases that aren't just
LM crap. It like you literally just
remove the actual interesting design and
like you remove all the logic from stuff
and you just end up cleaning up messes.
like dealing with LLMs. It feels very
close to just working with idiot
colleagues
on bad code.
I think it ends up just making a mess of
the trivial [ __ ] So you're like
everything else just gets more
complicated.
And a lot of the times the trivial [ __ ]
like you should not have huges huge
amounts of trivial mode.
Honestly, I think gamedev is harder.
At least with kernel dev, there's like
a lot of it is very self-contained and
can be tested formally.
You can still make a mess of stuff and
write the wrong kernels and whatnot.
Yeah, but the thing is the solution to
the bloated TypeScript web app thing is
for it to not exist. Like there's just
no reason for that [ __ ] to even exist in
the first place. [ __ ] should not be
written in bloated TypeScript
frameworks. Period.
You can literally just write the [ __ ] in
C actually to be fair, but not how our
field is. That's not my field. I mean,
look, if you're going to take an area
where there's literally impossible to do
anything anything intelligent because
just the people in that field are so
dumb that they don't have a single
redeemable like a single redeeming
quality, then like sure. But I I don't
find replacing [ __ ] that shouldn't exist
in the first place to be interesting or
useful.
I really just don't even consider
software engineering. You're basically
just like at that point you're just
[ __ ] handler professionally.
You just don't know how to use it.
Second engineers do.
No, I do know. You're dumb.
The thing just sucks.
You just don't know how to use it. You
can look at every single part of the
whole TypeScript, JavaScript, web
ecosystem, and it's all [ __ ] There's
like nothing redeeming whatsoever about
it.
Why is it always the people in my chat
that like type incoherent [ __ ]
constantly as well that are super like
TypeScript and LLM pill as well?
It's like consistent [ __ ] takes
If you would like the exact reason why
it's [ __ ] stupid, it's the same
reason that adding types to Python is
[ __ ] stupid. You add types for the
sake of type safety to a language that
is slow by design so that you don't have
to type it.
And the types in many cases less well it
depends with TypeScript but definitely
with Python actually make it slower
somehow. That is a terrible language
design. Now pair that with the bloated
JavaScript ecosystem in general
and the millions and millions of
redundant packages and the super super
bloated frameworks and no wonder nobody
can think straight.
C++ is way. See, this is like your
opinion is just invalid when you just
constantly every single thing you say is
complete backwards. Like
I'm not like the only experienced
developer that has this opinion either.
You'll see a lot of very experienced
low-level engineers saying similar
things.
If it exists at this scale, it must be
useful. It's just bloat vault. You can
throw 10,000 engineers at something and
hopefully you accomplish something in
the process. But if it's like 10,000x
bloated, All right.
My version of this Jess says, "I shall
never fear the mind of a man who does
not think.
decades of experience. I've been doing
this since I'm I was 16.
I've got a bachelor's from Stanford, a
PhD from MIT, and I have built the most
high performance reinforcement learning
infrastructure in the world.
So,
you can just go, oh, you're young and
inexperienced because you're still in
your 20s. sort of. But like I've built
[ __ ]
I've met many, many senior engineers
with decades of experience at top
companies that just [ __ ] everything up,
write 10 times too much code, and cost
their teams millions of dollars.
I can be in fact very open-minded when
I'm presented something that's like
actually has reasonable evidence behind
it. Right? The example I give, which is
still the most recent one, was uh the
Muan optimizer stuff. I thought all of
optimization lit was a mess.
I was wrong on that one.
So far, all the bloated big tech, not
seen any redeeming qualities from it.
Don't know what they're doing from the
dogma.
How on earth is this possibly dogma? The
stuff I'm doing is not the trendy thing.
It's a way out there thing.
It has proven poor hard performance
numbers.
And it's accessible to newer programmers
as well. I've helped dozens and dozens
of people get into the field
where all you can do is parrot big tech
big tech like the standard established
ways of doing [ __ ]
and tell me I'm young and inexperienced.
Who's arrogant now?
I literally will do stupid [ __ ] all day
on stream and I do not care if I look
stupid doing it. I didn't know any CUDA
at all. I still barely know any CUDA.
I just kind of bumbled my way through it
on stream and we got Puffer 4 out of it.
Thanks to a couple good contributors as
well.
definition of success.
Personally, Vault, I want to advance I
want to advance the technical state of
humanity. I mean, that's the lofty
version of it. Like,
I don't really see, oh, we built this
like service B2B service as useful. No,
I want stuff that gets into really hard
tech. um you know how do we accelerate
the usage of simulation across
industries?
I sincerely want this to get into
biotech
where we can start targeting major
diseases and aging. I don't know
anywhere near enough about those fields
yet. Um I suspect though because
simulation is so broadly used that we're
are going to be able to make quite a big
difference there once we formulate
things correctly.
Yeah, exactly. I'm not looking for It's
ridiculous.
simply because I'm expressing a
dissenting opinion forcefully like
is just madness.
I give plenty of credit to people doing
good work as well.
I wouldn't call myself self-made, Jess.
You know, I've been in a very privileged
position to do what I do, but I've also
worked very hard and I've given a [ __ ] a
lot.
Can good work be done poorly? Yeah,
absolutely. You can have um you can have
the key direction and idea correct and
fl uh fail completely on the execution.
I used VS Code for a bit and eventually
I landed on a form of it where I
basically just stripped all the plugins
and UI elements out of it. Um, so it
ended up essentially looking like a
double pane Vim like this. And then I
thought, wait, this is stupid. I can
just use Vim.
Yeah, I had to I did that for a bit
vault just because of the Docker
container plugin and then I was like
wait I'll just minify this container
and then I won't have to bother with
this crap.
It's not really worth this flame word,
Jess. It's just like it's just stupid.
I'm going to fix this environment.
Uh
I think we just had some bug with the
latest refactor of it. I think I screwed
up the reward structure.
See, what we need is not like we don't
actually need all these static tests,
right? What we need is to just have a
couple scenarios that we can check
learning on quickly.
Perfect. That's
this and this.
Time is it five.
Uh yeah, I know what I'm
wait on selfplay.
Yeah, let me stop getting distracted by
the stupid side monitor. And um
one thing to set up
and good
uh the return is now way too big. That's
why
Okay. Interesting.
Trying to optimize now.
this and it's a compute marketplace
symbol.
I can look at the changes real quick,
captain, because this is taking a while.
I'm just trying to remember all the
stuff that I've like set up with this.
I should probably learn to use clank
format to be fair.
Not with such a giant config, I would
think. But um
I could do I could have um
Yeah, I could definitely just some
reasonable thing on this.
I still think that generally like
manual semantic grouping of stuff is
going to be better than any of these
formatterers
obser.
So, is this the per player of size?
It would probably be the bindings, but I
don't see anything in here, I guess. Let
me Wait, where's the N?
It's called end of.h, which is kind of
weird.
I don't actually know if it'll build
correctly from N.H.
Continuous action size. I thought it was
discretized
And then you said um terminals and
actions are both float, right?
Like the dtypes
eventually though floats. You can try
continuous. It's just less stable and a
multi-discreet is way faster now. Like
we have custom kernel so multidiscript's
fast.
I'm not seeing anything obvious.
Captain, I would probably I would go try
running it with like one buffer and
thread zero zero threads or whatever so
that you take off the multi-threading.
probably like N for a few N's. Um, see
if you can get it like the address
sanitizer to compile with it.
Probably something's weird there.
We really don't we really don't see M's
like nanning in ports unless something's
very wrong.
then doesn't compile. Yeah, I saw that.
So, I think that there's a way you can
do it because what we do is we compile
the training code is CUDA, but the end
code is still compiled as C and it's a
static link. I don't know. I think you
can maybe have you might be able to have
the symbols on just the C. We definitely
need to do better debugging. I mean, we
do our um like our tests in C, just our
standard tests in C. If you build the C
standalone, you can check that. But
yeah,
double check the OB size for sure.
I don't see anything obvious though,
man.
is numbum agent set captain
um is numbum agent set like reasonably
because it reads so on it like on setup
it reads your environment's numbum
agents to figure out how many to
allocate to one.
Wait, is it one learning agent versus
one scripted opponent? Cuz in that case
then yes, that's correct.
It would completely break though if you
had two controllable agents for that.
Okay, that makes sense then. I I don't
see anything, man.
Uh,
how are they scaled, Captain? Like you
have gigantic values in there.
bit pack stuff. Well, that Bitpack stuff
probably has really big values in ops.
That can definitely nan stuff.
Might have to redesign some mobs a
little bit.
Why does this accept any jobs?
Why does this accept anything is my
question.
Why is the seller heristic?
I'm war.
Oh, I'm just dumb. I'm just dumb.
I'm very dumb. It's okay.
Very stupid.
Cool.
We make zero dollars.
Make zero dollars.
That was the intended effect. Vault it
like that's supposed to be it's supposed
to offer um at too high of a price.
Captain, can you just like crunch the
OBS into a roughly 0ero to one or
negative one to one range just to see if
that's the problem.
Like that should be quick, right?
Just to see if it's still NS.
You just I don't care if the obs even
make sense, Captain. I just want them to
not be like if you're bit packing stuff
so you have 255 in some of the obs or
whatever, you can very easily screw up
the normalization of stuff. I just want
the obs in a reasonable range. Like even
if it doesn't learn, I want to see if
that's the thing that's nanning or if
you have a memory corruption or some
weird thing, right?
Ah,
that's interesting.
I mean, all these things that are like,
"Oh, you want to feel old?" Like, that
see that feels like a long ass time ago
to me, man.
I think we're back. It might have perma
killed the X1 though.
[ __ ] reream, man.
It looks like they're all back up.
Extreme was killed. Great.
It says it's fine on my dashboard is the
crazy thing about it.
Stupid reream, man. My internet didn't
go down at all. It's just they're crap
servers.
But you're used to you're used to doing
things with crap servers, right?
I had one of my clients, but not the
other, DC and Srirachus earlier today.
They actually fixed that. Well, mostly
fixed that.
You have a thing that like you can set
to um
you can literally set the thing to like
teleport you out instantly
if you uh don't know if the minimum is
one or two ticks. It might literally be
two ticks. Two ticks DC
equals telly out. That can still
technically fail, but
you'd have to be way way unluckier
than it used to be.
Hey Jess. Oh yeah, there you go. The X
is back. Yeah, just reream servers just
suck. I don't know what to say.
This is uh the same,
right? Like,
Oh, it's forced to accept every job,
isn't it?
Is it zero? I see. I messed up the test.
Oh, it's trying to trade energy now.
Good.
Okay,
Cool.
This thing
and we do ah self rack.
We need to do by fra like this
88.
Okay, this is the wrong one.
Solve.
Okay.
Um,
okay. Well, you definitely can't do
this, right? It has to be eight and
three.
Almost an
tricky.
You can profit on this, but it's a very
slim margin.
It's
Let's just make sure it's not a reward
scale [ __ ] thing.
Might just be that. We'll see.
Let's
You want
Yeah, this is a client project.
Haven't ported it up to four yet.
Something's definitely screw.
Something's definitely free.
Not super stressed, honestly. I'm still
pretty I'm just pretty tired still from
uh the release.
I'd like to start puffer five, but I
actually have quite a lot of uh stuff to
do before I can even think about that.
This is just silly that this is not
working.
We keep building better software.
We do um contracted work. We take on
larger and larger contracts because the
software keeps getting better.
If you're doing this type of RL work,
like you're probably using Popper or
should be. Why wouldn't you want to have
us on your team?
Pretty simple.
same thing.
Okay.
This should be learnable.
Why does this have an episode return of
17?
That's the That's the problem. There's a
reward bug.
100%. We see it right there. That server
100% of our word bug. Cool. That's what
we needed.
I'll be right back.
contract. It can be. Sometimes it is,
sometimes it isn't like most things.
Oh,
stupid.
I mean, I don't like dislike making
money.
I'd rather gold bars just kind of show
up on a pallet outside, though, when I
get back to science.
That'd be nice.
Um, I mean, I never said that there is a
plan to IPO, right?
Running a public company does not sound
particularly fun.
didn't want to work anymore. I could
focus when I actually want to do
working.
This is kind of how it goes. Vault, to
be honest with you.
It's kind of how it goes.
to be honest in I kind of just do it
half the time. Like
I definitely get tired and just burnt
They're cool, but I don't think that
they go anywhere.
You know,
I don't think they go anywhere.
I kind of been here for 3 weeks and I
got [ __ ] to do.
Definitely something still wrong.
We're in negative profit.
I can try in the evening. Jess, I've
gotten delayed with this [ __ ]
I've just had to fix the sim for way
longer than I anticipated today.
I know. Anish
one on Discord doesn't work. Where's the
one on Discord?
Where's the one that people keep getting
off of Discord that they say doesn't
work?
This. Oh,
And this as well.
That's super data. This is why we need
to not have information in 10 This is
Yeah, vault. I know. It's such a new
thing, right?
Yeah, something's locked here and I
don't know what it is.
What are we doing here? This is a client
end that happens to be open source. It
is a compute marketplace simulator
and I am currently trying to get it to
train with the latest refactor.
actually this is progress
boards look reasonable now just why is
no learning
particular you're working on. Depends on
your experience level.
Most new contributors start by um just
building an environment to get a sense
for the project.
We're experienced RL contributors like
we have everything from like optimizing
our kernels to brand new algorithmic
research projects.
Really depends on your uh background
and interests.
in I study math.
If you're looking to learn, then my um
my suggestion would be you take a look
at these articles of mine.
These two articles are going to be your
best friend for getting started right
here.
They'll save you a lot of time learning
stuff.
[ __ ] man. So weird.
Trivial.
Yeah. So, um, RL has this formalism in
Markov decision processes.
I don't think that it's actually
particularly useful to think of RL in
that context.
well, there is a use a fair bit of
useful math in Sutton and Bardau.
It's mainly the whole advantage
estimation
chunk of things.
important sampling though. There are a
few things that need to be added to
that.
I mean generally it's just you formalize
things that can be formalized.
see how it is. But I can just like very
easily write down this policy
Well, I actually have got to run in a
minute or two. Um, I'm going to have to
just work on this tonight. I don't know.
This is super annoying. I don't know
what. Like, this is super simple. This
should not be this difficult.
But, uh, for folks watching, all my
stuff's on puffer.ai. If you want to
help me out for absolutely free, just
feed the puffer star on GitHub. If you
want more content, join Discord. Follow
on X.
There's still something scurry with that
Zuck fight.
I'm going to go probably practice the
fight a bit more later in the week.
I think I can literally AFK the Inferno
up until Zuck on leagues and then just
do Zuck normally.
Oh, it's just maxing its entropy, isn't
it?
I didn't really play when I was younger,
man. I found the game in college.
If you're looking for like well
prodduced crazy videos on the game
probably settled.
not just entropy maxing.
That's really weird.